Fox News sends Tucker Carlson cease and
desist letter over Twitter show oh boy I
love this totally insane they say
Carlson was abruptly pulled off the air
by Fox News in April as we know axios
obtained a copy of the Season assist
letter which the report said not for
publication quote Fox is continuing to
pay Carlson and maintains that his
contract keeps his content exclusive to
Fox through December 31st 2024 very very
interesting timing the report exclaimed
Carlson is making a First Amendment
argument for posting on Twitter and
asserts that fox has committed material
breaches of his contract yo they are
trying to silence Tucker until the
election is over they want they want him
in golden handcuffs and they used to do
this they many networks have done this
in fact I think it was gen yuger who
talked about it when he was at MSNBC
they basically give you no air time but
they're paying you so you're in golden
handcuffs they take care of you and you
can't work that's what they were trying
to do with Tucker hey look we're not
running your show anymore but we're
going to keep paying you and he's like
no I want to speak out I think the
machine the corporate Elites the neolibs
the neocons no it was uh what year was
it was it 2018 when uh Alex Jones and a
bunch of right-wing personalities were
suspended across all these different
platforms yeah 18. 18. it was like a big
perch because they were like hey wait a
minute these are the people that helped
Donald Trump get elected they're going
to be doing the exact same thing and
it's begun not just the daily wire but
also Tucker Carlson
the idea that you would take Tucker who
is someone that up think of it right up
until just a few weeks ago right one
month ago the number one name in America
in terms of Primetime news after Tim
cast IRL uh at least on on cable news
right 10 times bigger the number one guy
the number one guy and suddenly he's
summarily fired but not only is he fired
and in and I I'm just gonna say it in a
very disrespectful way the way they
treated Tucker
um his very last appearance he says
we'll see you on Monday so he didn't
they didn't even give him the
opportunity to do a sort of sign off
show or even come out over the weekend
and say hey this thing happened et
cetera et cetera no and if it was part
of the Dominion lawsuit that means they
knew in advance they were planning on
taking Tucker off the air and did not
let him know at all right yeah I guess
they didn't fire him I'm still trying to
get the Liturgy they did not they took a
show off the air but he's still under
contract so they're basically saying you
you can't work anywhere but don't worry
we'll pay you which is the same thing
they did to James the same thing James
will keep yeah I I wonder if Tucker's
show was part of his contract like we're
going to pay you for this show we'll
give you this amount of money so if the
show is removed from the contract
essentially the contract becomes null
and void probably kind of what Tucker is
thinking legally I don't know I feel
like if someone's willing to take a
bunch of money for a long-term contract
that's the price you pay when they
sideline you you're stuck you lost your
first amendment we're like you can speak
out but there's consequences in in the
form of getting sued by the person you
you signed the devil's contract with so
I don't know like the logical part of my
brain is like Tucker you're stuck tuck
you're stuck no he's not you like the
idea that he can't post videos to
twitter is absurd well that's all I was
going to ask the cease and desist is
just that he's speaking at all right is
that the idea you can't yeah there's not
a thing so they're gonna say
um you know and I'll I'll play The
Devils out because you have to be able
to give both sides even argument so I
disagree but here's what they'll say
they'll argue that even though he's not
broadcasting on cable news that he is
essentially continuing his show and
thereby competing with with what
previously would have been his time slot
so uh the idea is that you can't
continue the Tucker Carlson show or
anything that's similar to the Tucker
Carlson show while you were still on
contract with us so if you change the
format you think it would work like if
he had two guests in like a different
angle I don't no I don't think it's
necessarily the format it's the fact
that he's making this type of content at
all yeah so if he set up like you know
um like Tim like your daily show like if
he was doing like those types of Clips
which is kind of similar to what he's
doing anyway yeah
um they would still say that he's in
breach that's wild man that's
informational content making a 10 second
internet video like this is these are
contracts that were created before
social media existed they don't have any
place in the modern Market where you can
make a tweet make a five second 30 30
minute video when you're sitting on the
each I don't understand but he did so
then I guess the question would be what
if he was live streaming it just
directly from his phone right to Twitter
that is that the same thing where it's
hey I'm Tucker Carlson and I'm uh
talking about Trump's indictment boy
that was terrible and our country's
gonna have a civil war and you know Etc
would that be necessarily a violation
content I mean they'll argue they'll
argue whatever he does is
but none of it is but more importantly
notice that I I'm giving the argument
from how they would how they're going to
argue it in court they would argue that
him filming live streaming it is the
same thing as a show at Night Live show
right I think they would as well but
he's not going to have to deal with this
they're not going to court they're not
going to assume he because Tucker could
just be like oh you're suing me okay I
guess I agree with your lawsuit let's go
to Discovery I won't challenge it for
dismissal we'll straight to Discovery
and fox gonna go no wait don't because
all the Dominion stuff comes out
and they don't want that to happen and
he said already that there have been
member board members of fox who by the
way I'm sure are going to come up for
deposition if this goes to any type of
lawsuit that he's going to say all right
you you who else was in the room who
else was in the room okay you you and
you we're all going to sit down and
we're all going to find out exactly what
went down when you decided to summarily
pull the plug on the Tucker Carlson show
is Fox News the fox Corporation
right so they actually divested from uh
the the larger Fox that Disney bought
right so is it it was fun with something
I yeah I think foxcore for Fox News Corp
yeah I have to wonder then if the stock
price drops
in response to the firework Tucker
Carlson if the board can then be sued
for a breach of fiduciary duty class
action does he not have the option
though to just get out of his contract
and not be paid I thought he I'd read
somewhere that he had the option to
cancel his contract I don't think so and
based on my experience having similar
contracts from these networks you can't
you have to request they that like there
should be like a mutual break you can't
the purpose of the contract is so you
can't leave
otherwise there's no reason for them to
have a contract with you right
they say we want you to be only with us
for this amount of time you say yes and
they say we'll pay you x amount of
dollars if they break the contract they
have to pay him out for the full terms
and then he's free to go so he's making
that argument that they've breached
contract and I say it's kind of obvious
they did which is what happened to Megan
Kelly at NBC yeah and they let her go no
they fired her but then she went in and
got the full remainder of her contract
so she got paid and she got loose to go
do her own thing right away immediately
right but that's because she was fired
over the black it was like a black face
she said I don't understand why it's
offensive people all the time and it's
like she didn't even say anything
offensive she was just like I don't get
it can someone explain to me and they're
like you're fired right
but honestly like that's like Morning
Show banter kind of stuff that you would
do you know maybe like I'm a very smart
individual I'm sure she all knows what
white people don't like hey look she
made it like a bandit it was a big
mistake for her to try and do one of
these hokey morning shows her her
podcast now is substantially better and
successful I've I've always said
um you know and and and people know me
and Kelly and I have had our differences
but uh I vote I mean Kelly File was
fantastic when she was just the you know
the hard-nosed legally goal slicing and
dice in these cases and I think that's
where her podcast has gotten to at this
point and it's substantially better and
let's not forget she's the one who asked
Trump that fateful question about
calling them in fat pigs that's right
and then we got that magically won him
the election I gotta say I don't know
Megan personally that one thing yeah I
felt like she had a great kind of
evolution similar to Tucker Carlson
because I remember her being a sort of
neocon in like 2007. if I remember
correctly I remember not liking her at
all being like she's just a Warhawk
she's just parroting the mainstream
media narrative it's so annoying and
then all of a sudden like 2013-14 she
was like not hip to the crap and I
started to see her wake up and kind of
like separate herself from the pack and
and think critically and I haven't
really followed her work a lot but I
really appreciate that Evolution our
podcasts are great it's very good I
think this is just the the beginning we
are going to see a wave of censorship
we're going to see insane smears lies
cheating stealing you name it my
favorite is when they did that Stanford
study on like people spreading election
disinformation or misinformation or
whatever they put me on there and then
you have like I'm not gonna say these
people's names but there's one woman who
claims that I pushed the big lie about
Trump's election narrative which
literally I've never done and was
heavily criticized for doing it but
they've run uh ads to generate donations
claiming that I
claimed since the beginning that Donald
Trump actually won the election and he
was cheated which I've I never said I
said he lost because they were ballot
harvesting and because people were fed
up but they'll lie doesn't matter if it
makes them money if it wins some
elections they'll say whatever so I hope
you all are ready
I'm as ready as I can be man deep fakes
I am never really ready for the Deep
fake until I see it and then I'm like is
this happening we've had the first uh
political
campaign official deep fake act and
DeSantis of all people earlier this week
but that being said this is why if you
remember a couple of months ago I was
pushing deep fakes hard I was like
throwing them up once a week right and I
didn't know it would be DeSantis but I
knew that there would be campaigns that
start slipping them in that just very
sneak sneakily start slipping in these
deep fakes in addition to actual content
but you posted stuff like here's what
would happen or something like that like
here's here's I couched it I always
couched it and they uh I think it was
the RNC did an ad of what the future
might look what the future will be under
Biden well this goes back to LBJ it
shows uh deep fake images AI generated
images of Biden in situations that are
clearly not real and are explained as
fiction as the premise of the video
right the DeSantis campaign put real
life Trump in big block letters and then
showed three fake photos of Trump
hugging and kissing Dr fauci but they
were spliced in in so like you know
you'd call it like a six-pack right so
there were three real pictures yeah of
trump and fauci spliced in with three
fake pictures and I saw
I saw the detainer's campaign saying oh
well Trump post memes all the time Trump
post stuff uh no they called it whatever
they called it deep fakes too and then
someone shared Ron writing a rhinoceros
and I'm like sorry you believed that was
real which actually was a Photoshop
um it was even signed it was obviously
it wasn't he picked but the point is is
that no one was claiming it was real and
it wasn't slipped in you know mixed in
real and fake images together was real
and tagged is real right thanks for
watching this clip from the timcast IRL
podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8 pm and become a
member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time